tu sais qu'avec la gueule que tu as si
le malheur est hors-la-loi été condamné
à mort est ce que t'as vu ta tronche
julie t affreuse j'aimerais tellement
doute pour une fois tu sortes avec un
mec bien juste pour changer tu voudrais
pas ça serait génial tu vois un mec qui
serait simple un mec discret normal
regarde le mien
regarde moi ça est ce que il a une tête
de con lui banon et leur pas une tête de
con est-ce que tu la vois la différence
non mais tu vois ça devait passer à
temps de faire jeter raconter l'histoire
des supermarchés
quand on perd mais acquitté je suis
désolé chéri mais c'est vraiment une
grosse merde maintenant c'est terminé ma
petite chérie stone 10 et l'asie me
sauter bref mieux vaut que ça t'arrive
sans enfant parce qu'à pas battant le
mariage est comme sur les bras je ne dis
pas ça pour toi ça te fout vraiment une
vie en l'air nous un numéro super bon
plan pour se changer les idées
tu veux il super gentil presse wal comme
ça qu'est sûr qu'il est bien trop mou ce
qui alors banlieue mais tu es pressé non
on allume super attention voit
s'afficher l'appel de mama il est super
je sais pas il se passe des choses quand
même un peu plus graves comme
l'extrémisme par exemple je sais pas si
tu prends la sécheresse la famine en
quoi tu penses que j'avais il ya des
gens qui crèvent encore nadal vainqueur
et que tu restes cultura connaissent à
des primes allaient pas caricatural